"Making the Jump: How Desktop-Era Frameworks
Can Thrive on Mobile"
Tom Dale
>> Thank you so much, Ashley.
That was really amazing.
And before you go, I took a photo of this.
So this store, in New York, that sells karate
hip hop action/drama headphones and luxury
items.
Have you ever been in this store?
ASHLEY: No, I just stood outside.
I'll come back and let you know.
>> Awesome.
Thank you, Ashley.
Okay.
We have two more talks left today.
We're next, welcoming to the stage Tom Dale.
He is from New York City, of course.
He's a JavaScript thinkfluencer.
So this is going to be a think-piece talk,
I think.
He's wearing a suit today because he's a contrarian,
apparently and I think he wants everyone to
take a photo with him in the photobooth truck,
which every time I walk past, there's not
enough people in there.
So I hope you've all had a turn in the photobooth
truck.
So Tom's also wearing a suit because he wants
you to join his professional network.
He works at LinkedIn.
[ Laughter ]
He looks very professional.
So he's going to give a talk today on how
desktop-era frameworks can thrive on mobile.
I'm a little bit sad that he's actually in
the completing the look with the bowtie and
didn't go all the way.
Thank you, Tom.
TOM: Thank you very much.
Thank you all for having me here today.
It really is an honor to be here.
My name is Tom.
JSConf is a very special conference for me.
I was here about four years ago, which is
when I met Zahra, who you saw earlier.
Jed introduced us on the plane and then two
years after that, I proposed and we're getting
married in August.
So, for me, in particular, JSConf EU has been
particularly life-changing and hopefully many
of you can develop specially similar relationships,
professionally, I mean.
So today I want to talk to you about smartphones.
And in particular, I want to talk about how
tools that grew up on the desktop like Ember,
Angular, and React, can make the jump to the
mobile future.
And I think when people think about adapting
apps to phones, they often focus on the more
obvious differences.
So, for example, things like the difference
in screen size.
The difference in CPU performance, the different
input devices, touch versus a mouse.
But I think where the device is used is important,
too.
So, for example, a user on a mobile phone
is more likely to be distracted than someone
who might be focused on a task at their desk.
Or they might have a more intermittent network
connection than having a broadband Wi-Fi router
in their apartment.
So when phones can be used anywhere, there
are very few assumptions we can make, whether
that's how attentive the user is, or whenever
they have that Internet connection at all.
So I started working at LinkedIn in December
and one thing about working at a site like
LinkedIn is it reminds me of how truly global
the web can be.
In many cases, adapting to smartphones really
means adapting to new users.
For many people, their first computer is a
smartphone.
That means millions, maybe even billions of
people are going to be participating online
without ever owning a desktop computer.
And the more global your app is, the more
combinations of devices and networks you'll
have to deal with.
CPU power can range from a feature phone to
a low-end smartphone, to the latest iPhone,
up to a beefy desktop computer.
And network connectivity can range from GPRS,
to gigabit fiber, to nothing at all, just
ride the subway in New York.
So the problem with this is that without careful
design, it's easy to optimize for one combination
at the cost of another.
So let's take a look at two different users.
Let's imagine these two scenarios.
So user A has a very low-end smartphone.
It has a CPU has easily overheats and starts
throttling itself, and it would be borderline
useless except for the fact that it's not
full.
It Opera Mini which heavily processes requests
before the user gets it.
User B has a phone with a CPU that might rival
a desktop computer and they've got plenty
of fast storage.
But the problem is this person is traveling
without any cellular data.
So while they have sometimes access to broadband
Internet, it's only when they're within range
of a Wi-Fi network that it's useful.
For user A, anything that's JavaScript is
probably not going to be helpful at all.
Even if they stopped using Opera's proxy,
with the slow CPU meaning that getting the
JavaScript means long load times.
It's about keeping the file size as small
as possible.
For user B, we want our web app to work more
like a native application.
In fact, we'd be willing to spend more time
up front to load the entire app and as much
data possible on the phone.
That's basically what the App Store does,
right?
So that meant that he could use it when we
were away from the Wi-Fi connection that we
were relying on, and this user probably has
higher expectations on this app, as well.
It would be worth sending a bit more code
to get 60 frames per second animation and
buttery smooth scrolling if their device can
handle it.
So best experience on a slow device is often
radical different for the best experience
on a faster device.
And the more we try to take advantage of higher
end phones, the worst we've made the experience
for the majority of the world.
So what do you all think is the solution to
this problem?
I'll give you a hint, the initials are, "PE."
Any guesses?
That's right!
Panic and evacuate the building!
Very good.
The answer is supposed to be progressive enhancement
but one thing that's implicit, at least in
all the advice that I've received about progressive
enhancement is that you're supposed to do
it yourself.
It almost always means rendering on the server,
and denying yourself the temptation of using
too much JavaScript.
And browsers in the last ten years, let's
say, have advanced at a remarkable rate.
To me, it feels like the web has never had
more momentum add feature after feature.
And, yet, despite all this incredible innovation
from index.db to web workers, it doesn't actually
feel to me the experience of using web apps
day to day has improved that much in the last
three or four years.
So why is it that these radical improvements
in the browser don't seem to be translating
into radically improved web applications?
And I would argue the reason for this is the
cost of code is too damn high.
Taking advantage of all of those new features
in the browser requires a lot of code.
Native apps that work offline with beautiful
user experiences with hundreds of megabytes
and that's not even factoring in the SDK that
ships with the operating system on the phone.
On the web, just parsing and downloading JavaScript
can be enough to turn phones janky, and when
you start bundling your JavaScript into a
file, every byte starts to count.
And in turn, misaligned libraries have to
compete on file size rather than robustness.
So how do they achieve these improbably small
file sizes?
Often it's by persuading you that the old
thing is unnecessarily complex, the cardinal
sin in JavaScript but they've seen through
the BS and built something simple and that
leads to us the JavaScript simplicity fetish.
It is this emphasis on file size that leaves
the JavaScript community to this fetish, when
file size relies on simplicity and speed relies
on file size, and speed is paramount on the
web, we have to pretend that simple tools
are the best tools because what other choice
do we have?
The only way to run an app that run well on
slower phones and networks is write less JavaScript,
too often, handling edge cases and higher
levels of abstraction.
We eventually start to collapse under our
own page weight.
That's rational.
We've seen this play out several times now.
The more sophistication equals more code,
equals slower load times.
So the time period from 2011 to that we have
could be roughly broken up into the Backbone
era, and the Angular era and the Ember era.
This trio of eras can sometimes also been
known as the Ember era.
Now it's easy to become enamored with the
complexity of a tool.
And let's go back to 2011 and the most cutting-edge
tool that people were using was Backbone.
And people were saying, I love it, I can clone
it from GitHub, and read the source code within
a day.
But whenever my model changes, everything
breaks.
I heard about this new library called Angular.
Two-way binding is so simple.
You just change it, and it changes it on the
screen.
But a year later, it's like my app contains
a controller with 3 million lines of code.
But don't worry, React is amazing and so simple
because it's just the "V" in MVC and a year
or two into building your app you realize
it's 7 megabytes and takes two years to build.
So Don Norman what you may know as the author
of design of Everyday things, wrote this:
The numerous defeats in security measures
prompts my slogan, the more secure you try
to make something, the less secure it becomes.
Why?
Because when security gets in the way, sensible
and well meaning people develop hacks.
Like password rules are too annoying, people
just write the password and put it on their
desk.
So I would like to offer a different corollary
because when simplicity gets in the way, sensible,
and well meaning people develop hacks to defeat
the simplicity.
So how do we break out of this local maxima.
How do we write one app that can scale up
and down across these different devices and
performance characteristics?
Well, I think we can learn from native developers
because they've had to tackle a similar problem.
So these are different CPU architectures and
different CPU architectures have different
instruction sets.
If you write some code for x86 and you want
to run on ARM, they're totally different.
If this is how software was written, there
probably wouldn't be that much cross-platform
code and introducing new CPU architectures
would be borderline impossible.
We've figured out, a long time ago, that a
compiler can take a higher level program and
get it to run across all of these architectures
and if a new architecture comes along, you
just have to update the compiler and not rewrite
every app in existence.
So here's an existence of plying an LVM, and
taking C code and taking an architecture that
didn't exist in the '70s, which was WebAssembly.
And best of all, the compiler makes our code
not only run on all these architectures, but
it can be used to opt my our code differently
for particular characteristics of that platform.
So, for example, here's a paper about optimizing
GCC, where they said, finally, a new target-independent
feature could be implemented to take into
account certain specific features of the target.
For example, to make advantage of the Intel
Itanium, it's dating the paper, we've implemented
the support in the instruction scheduler.
And this is something that Ashley said in
her talk when I totally agree with, if there's
one thing that I want you to take away from
this talk is that modern web toolkits are
transforming away into something like a compiler
where instead of compiling your into native
code, it's going into a highly optimized version.
And I think this would mean taking an app
and delivering the most optimized version
to your device.
This could be like delivering new ES6 builds,
or transpiled ES5 builds and/or transitioning
from server-side rendering and client-side
rendering based on the network speed detected.
But most importantly, these tools can decouple
the file size.
If we can shift the complexity to our build
tools rather than being these monolithic runtime
libraries, we can reduce this pressure to
be simple.
So unfortunately I don't have that much time
for you today but I wanted to highlight three
things that the teams behind React, Ember,
and Angular are working on, in order to demonstrate
that these things are becoming mobile on compilers.
And so the first thing that I want to talk
about is React, and also Prepack which is
an open source tool for optimizing JavaScript
validation.
Prepack was released while on the plane on
my plane to Berlin.
But it was definitely true, the Prepack website
uses quite a bit of computer science terminology
to explain what it's doing.
It's genuinely exciting and novel but you
don't need to understand heap serialization
to understand why Prepack is cool for optimizing
web apps.
So to understand why Prepack is school, let's
see how something like a Rollup works.
It starts by analyzing which file it imports.
For each of those files.
Once it's analyzed the entire graph, it builds
a new JavaScript file that includes just the
modules that were actually used.
And once --
the final output is on the right.
Everything we've imported is inlined right
into that file and modules that aren't imported
with excluded.
This gives us smaller files by eliminating
the files that we don't actually use.
But it's not just modules.
Rollup can do other things if it sees things
that we didn't use.
Notice that we've added a new class to animal.js,
that's because Rollup is smart enough not
to include the feral animal class
static analysis just means figuring out things
about how a program will run without actually
having to run it.
Rollup isn't running your code, it's just
scanning to figure out what gets imported
and what gets exported.
And modules don't work inside of conditionals
so it knows with 100% certainty.
That's roll-up.
Let's take a look at V8.
Specifically, I mean, any JavaScript virtual
mean but we'll look at V8 specifically.
V8 can't help you with file size.
By definition, it has to have downloaded the
JavaScript file already but it can help with
making your code faster.
So this is a high level view of the architecture,
V8 and there's three major components.
I think there are V8 people here so please
forgive me if I get anything wrong.
So the parser which turns your JavaScript
into the instruction, and then the interpreter
ignition which evaluates your JavaScript and
then the Turbofan which turns your JavaScript
into something more time to generate but it
can run at truly ridiculous speeds.
And as your program executes, it keeps track
of how they're run and based on this information
it will ask Turbo fan to make optimized versions
of your that it thinks it will make it run
faster.
Not running it JavaScript probably would be
considered a bug because because it relies
on how the program actually runs, you have
to use the unoptimized code for a while until
V8 can make discussions and that that means
that every user pays that cost even though
the ended result is more or less the same
for everyone.
This is the tension that we have with static
analysis and dynamic analysis you pay the
cost once and all your users benefit but static
analysis can only get you so far because you
can only perform optimizations you're 100%
sure about.
If the module might get use, Rollup can't
use it because if it guesses wrong, the app
breaks.
Information about the runtime analysis can
collect information about how the program
actually runs so they don't have to guess
but requiring the program to run in order
to optimize it is a bit of a catch-22.
And then that's the opposite of what we want
on the web where things typically want to
feel instant.
So that's what makes Prepack so cool.
What it does is actually run you are why code.
Similar to V8, it's an actual JavaScript virtual
machine but rather than running apps, though,
it runs at build time and it reverse-engineers
a version that's faster for your JavaScript
to execute than the first time.
So this whole thing is a talk into itself
and I'm still digesting how it works internally
but let's just take a quick look at how it
works.
I know I showed an example also put so imagine
we're writing a library that prints the data
of JSConf EU, so publish -- so if we run this
through Prepack, you can see that it's turned
it you will into a string literal.
But instead of every user having to allocate
a data object, parse a date string, initialize
a date object, and generating an ISO-601 string,
and this is a contrived example.
And each of these small stakes may start to
really add up in codebase the sizes Ember,
Angular, or React.
And I'm hearing a rumor that Jason Miller
is going to release something called pre-Prepack,
that does everything that Prepack does in
only 600 bytes of code.
So let's look at Angular, it's on Typescript
that's just a subset of JavaScript, and those
types makes refactoring much easier as your
project grows, but to me, the most exciting
and underappreciated reasons for is the potential
for using that type information to more aggressively
minify your builds.
So
in this examiner we've renamed this variable,
fruit, to be called o and because these variables
inside this go nowhere outside of this function
can access it, so whatever we call inside
it is arbitrary.
Let's change this example a little bit and
instead of making fruit a string, we make
it an object with name property and even though
the variable fruit gets mangled, the property
name stays the same.
Now uglify.js has a property --
renaming properties can break things.
In fact, the readme of uglify says, note,
this will probably break your code, which
doesn't instill a lot of confidence.
So, for example, if we have an element and
we change its onclick property, if that gets
renamed to something else, then this is just
going to fail silently.
That click handler that we thought we were
handling just doesn't exist anymore.
And similarly if we look at a component, this
is a React component, for example, there are
parts of this object that are private and
then there are other things that are public,
meaning things like a library or a platform
rely on it.
Really what we want to do is mangle the private
stuff but make sure that the library can keep
using the public stuff and there's good news.
Google's closure compiler already supports
this advanced minification for JavaScript.
Unfortunately, it requires an notating types
with js style comments and -- approximately
seven people on the planet outside of Google
have actually gotten this to work.
Now the Angular team has released an amazing
tool called Sickle that translates a type
script project who the bizarre format that
compiler, and because Angular is written in
Typescript two, closure can do some advanced
minification.
The idea it more accessible to broader world,
and integrating into this NGCLI by default
I think would make a huge impact into basically
every Angular app.
So lastly I just want to talk about Ember,
and specifically Glimmer, which is the rendering
engineer in Ember, and also the library that
we extracted to be used standalone outside
of Ember a month or two ago.
So now in thinking about the rendering engine
is there's three things to consider.
How fast does it take to load.
But then once you have something within reasonable
bound of time, you want to look at how long
does it take to render a component for the
first time when you have to create brand-new
DOM elements.
And third, how long does it take to rerender
a component updating its existing DOM elements
instead of replacing them when the data backing
that component changes.
Okay.
So who remembers this app?
Yeah, the db bain of my existence.
This is Ryan Florence's dbmon demo app, which
heights the differential app and everyone
was competing to have the fastest score on
it.
And it's all anyone ever focused on but then
more recently the community's focus has been
on initial load times as people have grappled
with how we deal with these low-end phones
and slow networks.
And the tricky thing is trying to find the
sweet spot that balances between optimizing
the first render and optimizing rerenders.
Fundamentally, this is an issue of bookkeeping.
The more bookkeeping you do in the initial
render to make subsequent renders faster,
the longer that that render is going to take.
So consider a render using Bootstrap markup
on VirtualJS.
That makes a lot of sense.
This is basically just instructions for how
to create the real DOM but if a single part
changes we have to run the entire render function
again and that's quite a few allocations of
virtual DOM objects, not to mention that once
you have them, you have to then do this diffing
step to kind of reverse-engineer what changed
between last render and this render.
So the performance cost is probably negligible
but in larger apps you can see how it starts
to add up.
And in Glimmer we use Handlebar templates
and success how do we compile them into.
Come Ember's history, this answer changed
three times, first it was strings and then
DOM, and into with glimmer, byte code.
[Inaudible], and
a virtual machine that runs that compiled
code.
So in Glimmer we compiled this template into
a JSON object that looks like this.
Now, this probably doesn't book meaningful
to you but what this object represents is
a series of op codes, or instructions how
to build -- into integers, string literals,
so parsing is fast and memory consumption
is much lower.
When we landed Glimmer in ember 2.10, many
apps found their template sizes dropped from
75-85% which is significant.
Now if you look closely as 30 but we use integers
to represent instructions for compactness
and for certainly V8 operations but if we
were to operate it in a hypothetical linearized
set of instructions so when we take those
instructions and we execute them on top of
the Glimmer VM, it looks a little bit something
like this.
We have an instruction pointer that just goes
through this sequence and so this is going
to build an li element and then we're going
to move on and run the static add p code and
that's going to set the attribute and then
we're going to add another static attribute
which is the active class and then that's
the whole template and then we're going to
flush the element which tells Glimmer that
this is something to go to put in the DOM.
Now this isn't this is an easy example because
this is static.
But what I want mentioned yet is the Glimmer
VM is made up of two VMs.
One is constructing DOM initial on initial
render and the other is for updates.
So this is the program for initially rendering
this template.
Now we could run this again for updates, right?
But there's a lot of static content in here
and spending time executing op codes for static
content we know hasn't changed isn't a good
use of time.
In fact, we just want to focus on this dynamic
part and the way that we optimize is through
a technique called partial evaluation.
And partial evaluation simply means to generate
an optimize program by evaluating an initial
program.
And we use this technique to generate it automatically.
So initially as the initial program is being
run, we're generating a more optimized version
when the data changes.
Essentially these operations in the initial
rendering program are responsible for generating
their own subsequent code.
So the way this works is that we're going
to go through our op code for the initial
render as before that's going to open a new
div and we're going to set some status traits
on this, so in addition to appending that
text content to the DOM, we're also going
to generate an updating code which is to update
that content and it's going to include a reference
to what value what you were putting in it
as well as a reference to the text value that
you created.
Now when that data value behind that component
updates instead of going that whole process
again, all we have to do is evaluate our highly
optimized updating program which is just going
to take the old data out of the DOM and update
it.
And you can think of it doing as something
-- it's a little more complex than this -- but
you can think of why it ends up being fast
because it needs -- notice that basically
all the rendering library benchmarks only
tested pure dynamic content but it's not representative
of apps in the world.
So we created benchmarks that had a mix of
both static and dynamic content and what we
noticed was that initial I'm not putting the
other names here because it's not a competition.
I think I wanted to show that we're basically
in the same ballpark.
However, when we moved to updating other performance
what we noticed was that it seems like having
this optimized bytecode makes a big difference,
which can make a big difference, especially
on lower end phones.
So today we've talked about three popular
frameworks and things that they're doing to
improve performance on mobile devices.
It's -- there's an exciting trend towards
more sophisticated tools that can analyze
your app, perform optimizations that can be
time consuming, practically impossible to
do by hand.
Best of all code that clearly conveys intent
to other humans has a funny way of conveying
the intent for optimizing compilers, too,
p so in that we have be the idea that build
tools are -- sophisticated build process of
a modern web app.
This morning, Addy showed a bunch of techniques
for measuring and improving the performance
for your web apps.
That's awesome information but not everyone
can be Addy standing over them and reminding
them to take care of performance and spend
time learning about these techniques so I'm
incredibly excited about a community that
can help democratize and commoditize that
performance know-how.
So the best approach of approaching frameworks
and compilers isn't that they just help today's
by reducing the cost of code, we can build
better apps that don't collapse under the
weight of their own complexity.
This is a very exciting time to be a JavaScript
developer.
I for one am really looking forward to web
apps that load instantly, work offline, feel
great to use for everyone.
Thank you.